and Jacob has picked a tattoo for this
punishment I think I'm not going to show
you until it's done so I'm a control
dude and I figured I'd be able to okay
tattoo why don't you hop in a nutshell I
have tender skin oh me too dude I have
Googled butthole tattoos before I've
done them
oh it looks pretty
is somebody gonna tell me what that says
you shouldn't wear your small condoms
always yeah
um
like
but that says large I don't know if
that's gonna work for me I mean you're
talking to an old lady
is there gonna be any blood situation
I hope not but that's not the answer
we're gonna figure it out yeah okay
that already doesn't feel good now I'm
really making sure that I'm getting it
in there yep
that was not fast quick or painless you
want to see can I tell you something
hi ladies
ask me on tips on how to live life with
herpes it's not that bad how you doing
sir it hasn't been a problem well that's
good I'm glad you're here you know
syphilis is way worse anyways because
when I ask me tips on how to live life
with herpes at all
no all right cool it's not that bad
you're missing out you're missing out on
a great Community all right are you
ready yeah
yeah get the
does that say Jacob is my biological dad
yeah
ask her if she thinks it's possible to
take the chapstick out and just use that
tube I mean do you think it's possible
if I just like if I get a regular
chapstick to just take the chapstick out
and use the two like do you think
that'll work or like do you guys have
any extra slips like you know the rolls
of pennies when you put pennies in a
roll do you have one that's like half
that size
something like the size of a small
sandwich bag anything like that
that's a lot of hair sir yeah
Jesus Christ
this part feels like it's been some time
coming
a picture for an older brother to take
of his younger brother see you at home
yeah you nailed it
I don't know in case in case it does
happen at any point in the future I do
I'm out here just trying to embrace
everybody and make everybody feel better
I think well for me I have to tell them
before because for me it's a common
courtesy to make sure
he has herpes and you didn't know would
you still kiss him or would you ask him
that's a good question I mean I would
kiss him and I but I have herpes but he
doesn't know that and right I know that
he had herpes until the sign you know
what you know now what would you've done
before
I gotta say probably protected sex or
probably my best bet anything else boss
all right my friend thank you so much
have a great day now all right that was
so good do I keep going
like what you see you want a tip no
kid walking by
that was a bad one you ever seen a
Charleston like this feel free to tip
guys I'm trying to do something cheap
ladies and gentlemen I gotta fun this no
one on the corner got swaggered like me
ah come on nobody
y'all are Soulja Boy right Nola
we created us Superman yo
nope
yeah
this was the worst thing I've ever done
the next time I take my shirt off around
your mom did you tell her oh no I'm just
gonna let you deal with it when you get
home do you think I was gonna tell Mom
about this shooter said no she would
have maybe change it
[Music]